as up guys my name is a cello and
welcome to episode 10 of the Sparky game
engine series in which make a game
engine from scratch in C++ and OpenGL so
this is episode 10 okay every ten
episodes we're going to be doing a
maintenance episode what that means is
basically we're going to be going
through the code doing somewhat of a
code review and essentially making sure
that the engine is more or less okay we
might be doing some refactoring we might
which means we might be moving things
around and changing them and just
basically not really adding new features
but maintaining the code and whatnot so
what's going to happen as well with that
is we'll also basically blend in an
optimization episode into into episode
meant into every tenth episode because
this is basically what's called a I
guess a maintenance slash optimization
episode I'm also going to kind of
combine a QA kind of video into it so
what I've done is I've basically put the
chat onto the video so you guys can see
what's going on because this is being
streamed live and what happens is want
to do stream stuff live like like this
and then I put them up as a video on
YouTube people just don't have the
context of what questions I'm answering
and all that stuff so I thought it'd be
good if the chat is actually in the in
the thing so so yeah so chat is being
recorded
hopefully they behave themselves but
keep in mind the chat is a bit delayed
to what I'm saying because there's about
20 seconds or 30 seconds to stream delay
but that's the idea so the chat is going
to be in the video because we're going
to be interacting with them somewhat and
the chat will only be every tenth
episode so in other words every
maintenance / optimization episode the
chat will be in the video okay so it's
not like a new thing that we're doing is
just going to be every tenth episode
alright so let's talk about this so this
is what we had last time episode 9 it
look it worked pretty well we saw that
um it was running smoothly with 57,000
sprites which is the dream but
unfortunately the problem was the
problem was well there wasn't a problem
but we just we had no way to measure
performance so what we're going to do
today apart from maintaining our code
and whatnot we're also going to add some
kind of performance measurement thing
right so I want basically an FPS counter
kind of time a class so that we can um
so that we can essentially I guess
measure our performance pretty quickly
and display what our frames per second
are and I'm also going to introduce
profiling in Visual Studio in this
episode so that we can measure
performance and whatnot so basically
there will be there will be quite some I
guess we'll call it this will be this
will be pretty long episode in which we
don't really add anything new but it
will be a maintenance episode I've set
that roadie let's begin so what we'll do
is let's see okay so we'll get our to
the printf now so I think we'll just
start off with making a somewhat like a
timer class okay
so we'll go ahead and this isn't really
a graphics thing it's going to be in
utility so when utilities I'll add a new
item we can probably just make it header
only as well I'll just call it timer to
H okay and inside timer dot H we'll go
ahead and then we'll go ahead and I
think we'll just did we have we had fire
utils with that was that in utils no it
wasn't it was just kind of sitting here
so mmm we'll go ahead and say I'll just
yes Oh class timer okay so will you
we'll just for now because we're
supporting windows at least we'll just
use the windows header for this so I
know you guys are going to hate me for
using something as Windows only but
whatever if you're on Linux or whatever
you can just use like time spec and
other classes like that we're going to
be doing this instead so we'll have a
large integer so this is why it's fun to
use windows header stuff you get awesome
names like large integer
so we'll get stuff like large integer
which is always just the best so we'll
have okay let's okay
so I'll have a start for the timer so
basically what will happen is when you
construct this time it's probably make
more sense when you construct the time I
will just made a tatter only as well at
least for now because this won't be
something that we use actively and again
probably so when we do start our timer
we will basically set our start to be so
if we create if we quit if we query the
performance counter two wards and start
so we'll be using query performance
counter and all of that cool stuff will
make a large integer called frequency
will query the performance frequency
yeah with me so far
and we'll make frequency which will be
just a double so the idea is if we
divide anyway this will give us the
proper kind of part so am frequency
equals one divided by frequency dot quad
part okay all right cool so there we go
that is pretty much all we need to do
when we initialize the timer now other
stuff we will probably do is I don't
know it will have like we'll have a
reset well I will just have reset and
then we'll have like a way to get the
elapsed time time so float elapsed will
drown elapsed time reset will reset that
to zero so basically that's probably all
we'll have now honestly so reset will
set the M start to what the current time
is yeah so if we just do this that is
kind of pretty much what we need to do
and then elapsed will actually work out
how many how much time has
past since since like last time
so since start so if we make a integer
called like current will query the
current time and then we'll just okay so
we'll need to grab the difference so if
I just go I will need to probably using
in 64 as well cycles cycles so that'll
be e start what not - the starts and I
think we could probably just return
cycles times frequency variable which
should be correct I think that's right I
don't know we'll see
oh and we need to make sure that's the
right thank you stream see so now you
can see how the stream is helping me
instead of just being like oh I can't
see the chat well so anyway there we
have what looks like a an average timer
class
I mean it's Windows only but it should
be good so if we were to test this for
example we should be able to just say
time I dot H timer timer this is in
tills
so well that initializes it obviously
and we'll do that outside of sorry I can
probably bring this down you know what
it is outside of our window and whatnot
so we need to reset our timer every
other beginning of every frame and if we
like we can probably just grab the
elapsed time say at the end and that
should give us our performance in
milliseconds
okay so if we were to actually not want
will it yeah will this that will give us
our performance in milliseconds okay
good so let's just try this out
so we'll print out we use printf printf
so generally a bit faster than C hour
but also um they enable us to just
quickly append texts and stuff without
having to have a million things so let's
see if this works
yeah that's not right
hmm
that's a little bit weird
oh I'm not resetting well I mean I don't
really need to but we should probably be
resetting that as well and means that I
don't need that
well I mean it was doing that before
anyway I don't mmm current cycle set up
my starts
and
yeah okay we'll get rid of that I don't
know um I was resetting it anyway yeah I
mean well okay so if I don't do that oh
there we go that's the elapsed time good
so we do need to reset it there so if we
reset it and then we grab the elapsed
time that should be since the reset boys
reset do that should work I'm actually
kind of surprised it doesn't like that's
way too low unless it's in seconds it
probably is in seconds long no it's not
mm yeah not really okay let's let's this
that's kind of let's take a step back
stop guessing and actually go through
this so we got our frequency okay
so let's change this up a little bit so
we've got our frequency if we just say
well so it is in seconds people think
saying it was in seconds
hmm
okay I don't know I mean yeah okay I
guess that seems a bit right it seems
like it's been capped it thinking I
think we should probably I think we put
we should probably just let's try it
with this this should work so this
should be like I don't know a lot yeah
oh yeah okay so it it seems to be
working
everything is good in the hood okay so
now if we want the FPSO we've got a few
options that those are milliseconds the
frames right if we want the FPS we've
got a few options the best way well
there's several ways but what we could
do is basically we could have let's say
a we could have just a No well we could
have just like the current time yeah and
what we would do is time is just going
to continue increasing okay so what we
can do is we can basically get the
current time yeah which is time to lapse
and we could say time to elapsed - if
time that elapsed - say oh I don't know
some kind of time a variable we have
which we could just make large integer T
or something
I'm running out of variable names - T is
greater than a thousands that's an issue
and we could just say something like to
be plus equals a thousand
let's make it float okay so it's greater
than thousands and we'll add on a
thousand then we need to that that that
will basically happen once per second
accept the fact that jewelry's put once
per second not milliseconds so now
that's work and we should add on one
second so I think this should happen
once per second so let's just print off
hello just to verify that my timer is
working um set that up
probably should do it on the first one
okay it's definitely working all right
cool
so anyway there we have so this really
should be called timer but doesn't
matter we've got our time so yeah we
don't really need that we don't really
need this anymore if we don't want
milliseconds so I can really just get
rid of timer I'll call this timer we'll
just have time we won't have this and
then all we really need to do if we
wanted to count the frames is we might
have something like an unsigned and
frames equals zero it doesn't have to be
unsigned or anything we'll just have
normal frames equals zero then we'll go
frames plus plus we'll subtract the time
from that and we'll just say we'll print
out so we need to reset frame so this is
one once per second so of course into
the frames per second already set it
back to zero will pop in frames or fps
here followed by our integer and there
you are that should be frames per second
so we look that we should be at 60 okay
I'll accept 54 as well we are running in
debug mode okay cool and then this
should be like like four or something
once it stabilizes true story alright
stabilized by video so it's about six
cool I'm okay with that
all right anyway that is our timer out
of the way
um let's okay so one thing I should note
is we are about to be testing
performance that's that's kind of half
of our goal this episode so it's kind of
a bad idea to test performance in debug
mode because nothing is optimized
everything is basically configured to
this easy to debug so what we should do
instead is a basically user release mode
to do that we'll have to configure
release mode properly so if I go into
properties you'll see that like we've
only done debug mode we've really never
done release so let's start with
basically copying across many of the
properties we have here in to release
our output directory should be the same
so make sure that's good
yes we'll save so we'll go back to debug
will copy our intermediate directory
we'll just make sure everything is
pretty much the same I could just put it
into all configurations but I'm
deliberately not doing that that looks
good
these directories we'll have to make
sure they're copied otherwise Wow like
it probably just won't build so I'm just
making sure everything is the best
certainly look like it yes okay umm
debug well it's not what I'm looking for
look at the linker okay so if we now
switch our won't mode in to release at
the top here okay from debug into
release and we just hit f5 okay we've
got to copy the preprocessor definitions
as my stream is pointing out okay let's
go amp pre-press it from debug one thing
I've got okay so now it should totally
build and work
alright cool you see our consoles even a
bit smaller let's increase that back up
alright have it on before like 24 ish
that's probably big enough right okay
cool so now you can see okay and it's at
60 so good performance is better we have
not optimized this yet though if we go
back into release there's a few things
that we want to set up okay
particularly in the optimization
category so optimisation is set to
maximize speed that's good
inline function expansion we want to set
that to any suitable so we will
basically inline as much as possible
intrinsic functions yes I mean that
that's the default anyway favor size or
speed we want to favor fast code okay
that's important what else yes okay in
code generation in the floating-point
model we want to use fast and then
enhanced instruction sets we want to use
seemed extensions to well actually so
those of you don't know seemed or I
don't even know what it stands for I
forgot this is embarrassing but
streaming extensions
basically single instruction multiple
data yeah okay so seamed extensions is
what I should say basically allows you
to it allows the processor to act on
stuff simultaneously right so basically
you get 128 bits it depends on the sim
sometimes you can get 256 or 512 but the
idea is usually it's 128 bits and you
can execute operations to multiple data
in parallel so say you've got four
floats write a float is 32 bits you go
for them that's 128 bits so you could
probe for example multiply of that 4
with another FAQ for in one CPU cycle
essentially because it will do it in
parallel so seemed is very important you
should we should be we like if we
we're doing if we were really critical
about speed we would be using sims for
pretty much all of our maths the reason
we're not doing that is because so as
the name implies single instruction
multiple data it basically it only work
okay well that name doesn't really give
away too much but basically single
instruction means you know if we want to
have one instruction such as multiply
for multiple data such as again if we're
multiplying two vectors together we just
need to multiply each component to each
other it can execute that in parallel
very very very quickly so essentially
it's like one operation so it'll be four
times faster because instead of doing
four separate operations for each
component of the vector it will just do
it all at once very very quick it's
usually it usually makes your maths code
about four times faster just simple as
that
the problem is yes so we would be if we
were really critical with speed we would
be using seemd instead of multiplication
for example for our matrix classes and
vectors and all that stuff the reason
I'm deliberately not doing that yet if
the two is for two reasons one I don't
want to confuse myself and you yet but B
we will be trying to get M scripting to
compile this into JavaScript and for it
to work on the web and I don't think M
scripting is friends with seemed so yes
so I don't I don't think that that is
the best idea yet eventually when we
have some spare time and maybe in future
optimization episodes we will definitely
do this for desktop games okay so for
desktop implementations of Sparky we
will enable seemd and we'll actually I
mean it is enabled but I will implement
will actually do it ourselves explicitly
in a one long eventually but for now No
okay anyway that should be about it so
if we just hit OK and we build this one
thing you should note is that in our
directory now outside in Sparky we
should have been and then now you'll see
that there's this thing called release
and it will have it should be set up the
same way as debug and it looks like it
is okay cool so if we launch this we
should be running much faster of course
we are being capped by vsync at 60fps
which means that it can't go above 60
it's much
bigger than 60 so we need to turn off
vsync luckily it's relatively easy to do
in gel FW because they've pretty much
done it so all we need to do is in the
Windows EVP class we will be like gel fw
set interval or gel fw interval slowdown
gel fw swap interval we'll set that to
zero okay if it's 1 it means it'll be at
60 zero means it will be turned off so
now we're not locked and you can see
it's running about 690 well 700 frames
per second okay which is crazy fast for
rendering by 50 thousands and say 500
thousand 50 thousand sprites okay yes
they're not textured but no biggie
okay 700 FPS fifty thousand sprites
that's good and the other thing I should
probably note is that our memory usage
using this batch renderer is twenty
seven point eight megabytes for fifty
thousand sprites ok twenty seven point
eight megabytes if we take a look at the
other renderer which is our simple 2d
renderer which has one draw call for
everything
you should see a spectacularly different
result
okay well part let's just wait for the
stabilize okay so you can see with
release mode by the way it's running a
15 and not like whatever it was before
so it's kind of usable ish but our
memory usage is 297 megabytes about 300
Meg yes yes that's not good because
queuing up all those things and it's
just it's being ah not very nice okay
so that's something to note as well not
just performance memory usage 300
megabytes is a lot 300 megabytes is
probably what you'd expect from a game
like like this just for everything
though not just the sprites so yes this
uses 27 megabytes and it's much better
okay cool apart from the fact that it
runs very fast as you can see so that's
very very very cool now let's let's
continue on so one thing I want to
mention as well is
we should probably talk about profiling
so now that we've gone ahead and we've
been blind at the timer class so that we
can actually do this let's actually take
a look at the visual studio profiling
tools release mode is a good place to do
this in make sure you're in release mode
the problem with profiling in release
mode though unfortunately is all the
inlining okay inlining will make it
difficult to debug certain performance
like boundaries basically and
bottlenecks but we'll try our best
anyway so the way we profile in visual
studio and luckily this is included in
community edition but under analyzed
you'll see profiler okay we want to
basically hit analyze profiler and you
probably won't see this I've actually
done this before on this project on
stream but outside the videos so this
will probably be unfortunately set up
for us so if I quickly just open up I'll
try and reset it to what it should be
for you guys because it won't it won't
look like that view I can only fire
maybe was on a debug windows no it's not
you where's what profiling stuff other
windows nope
whatever I'll just um if I hit like new
performance session you'll pop up so
performance so I'll try and I'll
basically delete all of these okay and
it should
this is probably what it would look like
for you so if you hit analyze profile
okay yeah so start with revving balls
and stuff will be not good so if you go
analyze profiler and then new
performance session okay under targets
you can add a target project so it'll
add Sparkle and now that you've done
that you can basically either go analyze
profiler start profiling or under
actions it'll be here as well so we want
to hit start profiling with we want to
head start with profiling paused the
reason we do that is if we don't it'll
basically profile all of the we
basically want to start profiling when
it's actually running okay what I mean
by that is and stream needs to come calm
down about the turkey by the way because
I am cooking a turkey right now but it's
totally fine it's definitely not burning
I mean I'm the chair now I don't burn
turkeys I professionally cook them so
they're fine don't worry chat don't
worry
yes so we don't want to we want to start
profiling when we're actually playing
the game and the reason we do that is
because we don't really want well in
this case at least we don't want to
profile this for loop that adds 50 to 57
thousand sprites right we want to we
don't want to profile that we just want
to profile the actual rendering
performance which is why it we don't
want that extra data floating around so
if we start with profiling paused you
might have to accept like some kind of
you might you probably need
administration administrative
permissions for this if you just hit
once it's running if you just hit resume
profiling it'll start gathering data so
you might want to play around with it
make sure everything's running well this
is our batch render by the way but make
sure everything is running well yeah it
looks pretty good let's hit stop
profiling you can profile for as long as
you want I think that's probably enough
sample to learn all right cool so mmm
wait for this to prepare open the report
hopefully my FaceCam and whatever will
not hide this too much if it does I can
just pop it out so don't worry okay cool
so
okay this is great so if we look at this
one of the ball next I'll kind of show
you how to read this because it can be a
bit weird to read for if you've never
read these things before but this is our
CPU usage this line it's not that useful
I mean if you go into stuff like if you
okay so this this hot path is basically
as the name implies hot path it's
basically where so the hotter something
is the more time it takes okay
so n vo GL v 32 dll is Nvidia's OpenGL
driver okay so basically that is taking
up 30% of our time okay main is taking
up 99% of our time which I would hope
would be the case because it's all we've
got
um but inside that the most the the most
expensive operation we have is actually
calling functions in NVIDIA OpenGL which
is good because that means that our
OpenGL calls are what's taking up the
most time and not our code which is
probably good now if we click on this
again this might be a bit difficult to
read because it's in release mode boof
we cook it if we click on main for
example this isn't do about actually let
me um let me move this stuff over a bit
if I I'll just I'll pop it into I can't
and won't let me pop it into these
things okay I'll um I'll pop this over
here and then I'll just drag this like
this so that it's not being taken up by
the FaceCam okay cool so this is the
profiling stuff this is this is our
startup stuff cool this is our main so
we see that the function body whatever
to the function body itself takes up 50%
but from there these are the functions
that get called as you can see you might
expect out like stuff like when render
it up again or render it or submit or
window to update to get cold but they
don't because they've been in lined so
it's a bit difficult to that's why is
that is difficult so we will up I'll pop
this into debug mode in just a second so
that we can actually see our stuff in
action but we can see that the biggest
the biggest bottleneck in our
performance right now is actually rent
beginners is surprisingly quite big and
I'll tell you why it's because of the
binding but 57.4% of our stuff and this
isn't just of like this this is of our
entire application so 57.4% of our
entire application is spent on
submitting this prize for rendering
you'll see that the actual rendering of
them because it's one draw call is 0.3
percent of our time ok window dot update
is taking up 11.6 percent of our time
swapping the buffers that is absolutely
fine not something we can control any
way we can control all this stuff so
render adore submit is the biggest thing
now if we try and go into there you can
see we can't because it's been in line
so will will tell it not actually we
don't have to go to debug mode we can
just tell it not to in line our code
will do that in a minute but the idea is
that's basically the gist of how you can
read these things as you can see it's
incredibly useful because you can see
exactly but the more read something is
the more expensive it is right the more
the more time it takes up the more
samples that takes up right if you go
into call tree as well you can see
exactly what's going on so inside main
unfortunately again it's really hard to
read because it's inlined everything and
it's basically going straight to the
OpenGL drivers so yeah I don't know why
I closed that whoops
ah no here is okay so yeah which means
it might not be that good which is why
our functions you can see out there
really only them the only function we're
on is main because everything hasn't
been in mind so we'll we'll definitely
pop out of that in a minute I don't
think anything else will be too useful
here okay but that's the idea so it's
really important to do this stuff
because you can see exactly where your
performance is being spent let's go
ahead and stop the inlining madness so
if we go into our Sparky core we
right-click on this we hit properties
under release mode if we go into
optimization and you'll see this inline
function expansion we did change that to
any suitable we're going to just put
that to disabled which means that
basically the compiler will not inline
functions so inlining is the process is
basically getting rid of the function
call by just pasting its contents
to the path so for example render it'll
begin does this stuff so what it will do
it it will just kind of take this stuff
and just pop it here and replace the
function call because that means it
doesn't actually have to call a function
okay so that's kind of what inlining
does very very broad kind of definition
of what inlining does if you want you
can research it more but that's the idea
so if we get rid of inlining and we go
ahead and under our performance Explorer
which is hidden over here if we go ahead
and go actions start with profiling
pause again and wait for it to recompile
our code with the new optimization
properties we've given it play around
with it you can see how much slower our
code is first of all yeah you can see
how much inlining really does the reason
it helps so much is because where we're
going where amaway iterating through
57,000 sprites which means that is doing
57600 function calls per frame we if we
just got rid of that basically we just
got rid of 57 57600 extra function calls
by inlining them okay very important
stuff but anyway let's go ahead and hit
resume profiling we can probably get rid
of this now I'll pop it right over here
at the end of my eighth gap resume
profiling so inlining is important but
again it kind of doesn't help us
performance tune oh I shouldn't have
done that I dragged the window I dragged
the window which would have stopped it
and messed up all the data because it
would have paused let's get rid of that
delete okay let's do it let's try that
again
so I'll just again I'll start with
profiling paused I'll resume profiling I
won't drag the window it's time we'll
play around with it just a little bit
and should be enough okay so we'll just
go back and we'll stop refine now we
should see some slightly different data
okay so yes you can see that now instead
of an video opengl we see this so if we
click on main here to go to this we
should see something quite different
instead of this stuff you can see the
called function since since nightly
lining are actually our functions which
is very very good so you can see that in
this thing by far Rand Rho dot submit is
first of all taking up more than 54%
does that mean that everything else is
running faster no it just means is
taking up less because it was it's it
was in lining it so render it'll submit
is taking up the most so if we click on
submitter we can see exactly what is
going on here so yeah most of this stuff
we kind of can't really avoid we can
avoid it by not doing these these
mathematical operations are pretty fast
I'm not going to say that they're our
bottleneck really we could the one of
the biggest bottlenecks is probably the
color just because it is a wreck for
whereas we could just have it as an
unsigned int for example I honestly
think that's probably yeah that that's
definitely hiding that's definitely
taking up a few frames or I should say a
few a few milliseconds overall and a few
samples okay so we can probably get rid
of that and change that well wool will
play right okay well well since this is
an optimization episode we'll go ahead
and refactor color to be an unsigned int
and we'll see if that works better so
anyway that being said the point is we
can see exactly what's going on here so
it's it's seeming pretty good um and
again it should be pretty good because
it's our batch render I specifically
wrote it to be pretty good right I
didn't write it to be terrible now I
don't you won't want to see you all want
to see what is the bottleneck of our
batch render or power not batch render
or I should say so let's go ahead and
start with profiling pools again this is
our old renderer let's let's wait for it
to stabilize I don't know why the first
few frames are very sorry but let's
resume profiling
um yeah it looks pretty good
stop profiling
okay and here we go so um now you can
see that before submit was taking up the
most time now flush is taking up the
most time so if we click on main just so
we can see what's going on submit is
really taking nothing it's that good are
you suddenly like oh well submit is
taking nothing that means submits really
fast the answer to that is unfortunately
no submit is no faster than it was
before
write submit well it actually might be a
bit faster because all it's doing is
queuing but my my goal here or my my
point is that it's not necessarily
faster just the other thing is taking up
much more time okay so you have to be
kind of smart when you read this and you
can't just assume that okay less numbers
equals better or more non-secure better
if it's a percentage right it's not a
millisecond count it's just a percentage
so of our time spent total so ninety
seven point eight percent of our entire
run time for our game or our game engine
ninety eight percent is the flushing so
what on earth is going on in there let's
try that flush well draw elements are
taking up 30% which Spradling isn't even
that much right you'd be like well out
of like ninety percent I assume this
would be taking up this much if we go
back for a second so flash
was blind happening okay so that's even
worse well so let's go to flash okay so
yeah so draw elements is taking up heaps
as is a sprite get shader now the other
thing that's kind of important to note
is that binding our vertex array is
taking up 30% of our entire entire
application 30% of the time for our
entire application is spent on binding a
vertex array yep I was telling you guys
that binding was very expensive it is
thirty third almost a third of our
entire game is spent on binding vertex
arrays we don't want to do that that's
one of the reasons the batch render is
so much faster not just because of the
all like drawing everything in one draw
cool thing but also because of the fact
that it's not having to bind it very
spry right all it is here is bind bind
bind bind bind for every single sprite
we have here so that is it so a third of
our time is spent on draw elements a
third of our time is spent on binding
and the rest sister is spent on like 10%
is still quite a lot that's being spent
on uniforms uniforms are quite expensive
not to mention that the other thing is
set uniform get uniform location as you
can see does take up quite a lot get you
from location takes up 2.6% we could
definitely optimize this by having a
dictionary or a map of our of our shader
locations of our uniform locations so we
could sort them we could the key would
be like the name and then the the other
thing would be the Android or GL into
write which will be our uniform location
so that once we get this location once
we know where it is for that particular
shader is not going to change so why do
we need to query OpenGL for it again
let's not do that let's just store it in
a cache basically so by storing it in a
map so we should do that we're not going
to do that now though because that isn't
really a bottleneck for our batch stuff
right now but that's something that you
could do in probably something that I
would recommend to do okay because part
of set uniform right is actually in fact
as you can see 2% of our entire runtime
is the if we go back to here for a
second actually you can see that getting
home location is taking up 2.6 percent
and the rest is the uniform matrix for F
V call ok that's taking up the remaining
7% so let's put quite a bit all right
and again these numbers are relative to
the actual entire application not just
this obviously otherwise it would add up
to 100% it doesn't ok anyway that's it
that's all I wanted to show you guys in
terms of performance um
let's make let's try and get the color
stuff to work a bit faster and then
we'll then we'll talk so if I go into my
performance explorer which is over here
I'll just go ahead and delete these
three reports just so they don't confuse
us and I do
the wrong thing I meant to actually
delete them
I didn't delete them I just remove them
so you know open containing folder even
know where they're stored here they are
so before us the actual session these
are the performance ones I'll just hit
delete okay all right cool so that's I
just do that not to confuse us so if we
go back here and we profile the batch
render again yes that was what nice
looking good let's resume profiling yeah
so we'll gather a bit more data this
time I let it let it run for them for
about 10 to 20 seconds also to get it to
get it the best ok that's good let's
stop profiling now
okay so there's a report on so if we
take a look at this report now so submit
is taking up the most we knew that but
what we probably didn't know is let me
just i might just bring this out
fullscreen is that so so color isn't
taking up that march it's taking up
about like 0.5 ish I honestly don't see
this as being much what performance gain
at least as much as this this one's to
get up to ops and okay we'll go ahead
and do it and we'll see what happens so
this was our current setup right submit
was taking 68.3% that's all we need to
know and it was running at about 400 380
to 400 frames with out inlining and
about as you saw 700 frames with
inlining okay so fully optimized
basically it was running at 300 frames
at 700 rounds per second so remember
that data write it down somewhere if you
like I'll just give a stream to remind
me low okay so we'll close this now so
let's go ahead and check and take a look
at this the one thing I want to mention
really quickly as well is what we did
here is in our batch render adults ABP
I'll just close performance Explorer one
thing we did in our batch render dot cpp
was we i'll try and make sure that the
chat doesn't get in the way
in our vertex are at your pointer we we
basically yes so we with the way that we
were calculating the offset of this was
we were just going three times size of
float what happens though if we were to
go into say this and maybe as i said we
were we would be adding texture stuff
maybe we want to push that down don't we
what happens is we need to go back here
and change everything manually so
instead of that we can use something
called offset off so let's quickly
offset false let's quickly just take a
little bit off set of I mean it's pretty
simple the only reason I'm going to this
page for you is because I forgot the
header and which is defined in okay C
standard def so then this define
basically will calculate the offset of a
particular member in say a struct for
example okay so if we close this and we
go into batch render LCVP dot H I know
the capitalization here is a bit more
that's all right yeah let's see better
under a dot H on my other monitor for
some reason okay so if we go ahead and
include a vast then over here all we
need to do really is instead of this 300
get make sure it's in the view instead
of a three times gel float all we really
need to do is be like I want to meet
offset of the striped which is vertex
data and then basically its member which
is vertex data excuse me
color and that's it and if we do that
and we launch this again we should see
that it works exactly the same as before
yeah it works the same but we basically
went out when our using something that
isn't just basically hard-coded right
it's actually being calculated now
properly and if we move these around it
won't affect anything just a quick tip
that I wanted to point in anyway we're
going to be changing color to a or at
least for now to a I'll just comment
this I won't bother math throwing it to
an unsigned int we'll just go into color
okay so what we need to do to change
this now over here we should change this
to GL unsigned byte I know I put int but
it's going to be an unsigned byte
normalized I mean it will be normalized
because
ah Oh actually hang on a minute don't my
eyes on bite I guess so yeah well so
we'll put true here and then let's see
that looks pretty good
okay and then the major thing that we
need to do now is convert this color
into something that isn't that so if we
go ahead and say let's just
okay so first up let's extract all the
channels you guys know how to do this or
at least you should so we'll multiple so
the color color right now is in between
zero and one
all right we want to change it into
normal ents so color times 255 is how we
can get it into an RGB thing and if we
want to extract it now all we have to do
is if we shift it by so rare what am i
doing oh it's already separated well
what I meant to do was this let's go
ahead and just go Kahlid x times 255
oops GB hey I think it's actually I
don't even know what the format is
um I think it's I think it's RGB a but
it's like some other bit format thing
like big endian or something I don't
know
I don't unload big fan of and eNOS in in
general story so anyway now we've got
this let's go unsigned and color
I'll see because Carla's taken and we'll
go ahead and I'm going to just believe
that these colors aren't going to be
greater they shouldn't be greater than
255 because that shouldn't be greater
than one so well we'll trust it will
trust it so we'll go ahead and we'll say
god I'm gonna have to remember this I'm
pretty sure a is I'm pretty sure a is
the first thing that comes up so if I
just go ahead and um
I don't even need brackets so I don't
know I'm going to just no it's not is it
oh I wish I remembered this stream any
help I don't remember what I remember
what is it the channel is in I'm just
gonna say a it's probably not okay yeah
that's right thank you
eat play hey so a B G alright so that
should be correct so if we go ahead and
set that through these these puppies
hopefully this will work
yeah it does
are we faster I think we are I think we
are I unfortunately forgot what the
performance was before I think I think
it was about 400 so we look like we're
about 70 frames per second faster if we
could if we quickly go ahead and check
with our performance so analyze profiler
started riffing paused
yep gather your data
all right stop rolling so it was like
68% I think right stream remind me I
asked you guys to remember it for me
well it's like 70% so that probably
wasn't a great indication of stuff but
when we know that we were 700 FPS and
yes it it's because of CPU caching and
whatnot it's probably not the best idea
to actually rely on that profiling data
for that particular thing so what we
should do instead is yeah it was like
300 Z's so it's like a 100 frames per
second faster apparently so let's go
ahead and just we know that it was
exactly 700 before when we had inlining
so if we changed and learning to any
suitable wery compile all this stuff and
we take a look hopefully it'll be above
700 fps and we would have done our first
real optimization so cute
and I see an 8 there so Wow look at that
performance boost almost 200 frames per
200 frames per second faster see that
amazing that is more it's growing that's
weird that's suspicious but ok it's
growing
anyway 920 frames it looks like up is
dropping yep no 920 frames are you guys
amazed I'm amazed personally so anyway
that is going to pretty much wrap up
this episode because I think we've done
a lot before we go though I do want to
show you guys how these episodes will
run from now on so this was like a
maintenance guy episode but we didn't
really to do too much maintenance
because there's took up more time than I
thought because I had to introduce you
all to profiling but the point is on my
github account under Sparky ah under
issues oh yes that reminds me I should
fix something this is where you can open
up issues so if you go ahead and click
new issue and you just anything in
Sparky that displeases you usually bugs
and stuff not just something like oh I
think this should be like yeah you know
honestly anything that you find is an
issue in terms of like you would rather
have it this way or you try to use it
you're like maybe that maybe it should
this kind of usability whatever open up
an issue on on github just any time and
the next time I do one of these
maintenance slash optimization episodes
slash bug fixing episodes which will be
every 10 episodes I will take a look at
all these issues and I'll basically go
through them and make sure that they're
either that they're basically fixed so
the first first one which is suspended
by fatality was armed including better
intro to times in Maine one thing I want
to quickly mention and I think I was
doing that I remember seeing that when
I'm watching my own video when I was
editing it yeah battery and ro twice
that should be that one thing I will
point out there was anything in Maine
one thing in Maine that probably say
takes naps at 10:00 one thing I should
say that's probably important is
anything in Maine do not take it too
seriously okay in fact don't take it
seriously at all it's basically a joke
class it is literally it's a joke
because like for example I'm making I'm
allocating so much memory for new
sprites but I'm not even deleting it at
the end Lowell why you doing that you're
terrible people source program except I
don't want to hear it this is just a
main class this is not part of the
engine that's why it's not even in the
source directory right it's just a main
class so just in the future nothing in
here is an issue okay you can I can't
hurt you can totally open it up as an
issue but don't see it as an engine
issue because this isn't part of the
engine at all it's just a test class so
obviously I'm not going to spend time on
making sure it's good because it's going
to it's not part of the engine okay it's
just there for testing all right now the
other issue was actually Mihai opened up
this issue but basically Matt for
multiplication doesn't work correctly
okay one way we can test this is by say
rotating everything maybe try and maybe
just translating and rotating you're
doing a bunch of crazy stuff with it
so right now ah well you know what we
could probably say this will be
interesting
okay easy way to do this let's go back
into
Oh in fact we can just do with you okay
so I don't know if we have say a matrix
so we'll call this Matt and this will be
a maths Matt for I have to do I have to
use the math namespace do i why do i yes
no i don't okay
so a translation and we'll just go back
three five five five
I don't know then we'll rotate it around
that pivot points and then we'll
translate it back for example it doesn't
really matter
Matt times angle
okay so we'll have to actually do this
live and by live I mean in here so we've
got our time so time that elapsed
divided by whatever I'm not actually
going to make this time like a timer die
don't care
um and then the axis will go z-axis
which will be in like a kind of 2d
rotation all right so if we do something
like this and we go ahead and say shader
dot set uniform at four
let's just say what this have what
happens here nothing that's fantastic
why why did nothing happen that Shay
exists are we and we're not good rendre
why did nothing happen that's weird
where are shadows model matrix on my
timer is too slow yes that is also
something that could be the case so
let's where's Maine Maine is gone oh my
goodness where did you go okay that's
probably okay that is weird
um Wow well as you can see rotation is
working perfectly if we just had
rotation I think it would actually be
working so let's try that okay
not that's not even working okay now now
I'm suspicious I know it is working oh
so slow
I like those artifacts though they look
weird times 100
okay cool so that's working it's
rotating around that point I'm pretty
okay with that I mean those visual
artifacts are a bit annoying but that's
that's for another episode now let's try
some kind of multiplication so mat for
mats equals we've had and deleted
everything let's just controls added a
bunch of times okay all right so as you
can see it's rotating in more than just
the z-axis something is up with this so
we should probably fix it and luckily I
already fixed it so this is a solution
as you can see basically what we were
doing is we were setting the elements
directly we need to basically put them
into their own array and then we can
just use mem copy to copy them okay so
basically if we go into mat 4 which is
on the mouths Matt 4 we'll go ahead and
make a float called I'll just call it
data like I did in the other thing
instead of some plus equals ll know this
stuff is obviously here but instead of
our setting elements to some we're
setting data to some and then at the end
we're just going to use mem copy to copy
so our destination is elements our
source is data and the size is going to
be the size and bytes so it's going to
be 16 because that's all you know 4
times 4 times the size of float which is
what these are stored in ok so if we now
test it out hopefully it will rotate
properly and you can see it is so it's
rotating around an origin of like 5 ok
which is what we're did we're telling it
to do ok cool so that is a quick bug fix
that I want to implement everything else
looks pretty good again if you find
issues just post them here and I'll fix
them in the next maintenance episode all
right cool
I don't think I miss anything so if you
guys enjoyed this episode please do not
forget to hit the like button and I'll
see you guys next time with episode 11
in which we'll probably be doing layers
okay so our next and next episode will
plan out the next 5 episodes so I'll see
you guys then good bye
you